J’ai rompu avec Florent.
C’était plus possible, il connaît qu’une chanson.
En plus, il a rompu mon secret, ça, je suis désolé, c’est impardonnable.
Ouais, j’avoue, ça se fait pas.
J’espère qu’il s’en remettra le petit père.
En attendant, faut qu’on décide de ce qu’on fait.
Par rapport à quoi ?
Aux réseaux sociaux. Y a des photos de nous qui circulent, on n’a jamais rien demandé quoi !
Et du coup, ils me posent des questions. Y a des rumeurs.
Du genre ?
Sur le fait que soit disant, j’aurais mis le grappin sur lui ! Parce que je voulais profiter de sa fame,
que je sais pas je l’aurais émasculé et que je voulais des enfants avec l’oreille absolue. Enfin, les gens, ils sont...
Tu l’as vraiment émasculé ?
Du coup, je ne sais pas ce qu’on doit faire. Est-ce qu’on doit communiquer dessus ou pas ?
C’est un casse-tête ce truc.
Bon, je vais pas vous apprendre que si les réseaux sociaux sont un outil formidable pour communiquer avec des gens,
partager son travail d’artiste, trouver un travail ou adopter un pôtit chien,
ils ne sont pas pour autant un monde merveilleux où l’on peut tout dire et tout faire.
Vous avez tous en tête au moins plusieurs histoires de harcèlement ciblé sur un réseau social quelconque,
peut-être que vous en avez même été victime vous-même.
Et évidemment, si je vous parle de ça, c’est parce qu’Internet n’a jamais échappé au droit et au juge.
Notre liberté d’expression en France est encadrée.
Et quand je dis ça, on imagine que l’on est muselé et censuré, mais c’est pas le sens de mon propos.
Si vous tenez des propos homophobes par exemple,
bah vous ne faites pas qu’exprimer une opinion en fait…
peu importe que vous l’ayez dit pendant une assemblée, dans une colonne de presse ou sur Twitter.
Bon, ça c’est la pratique.
Techniquement, on pourrait et même, on DEVRAIT poursuivre ce type de propos.
Mais je ne vais pas vous apprendre non plus que l’on sait que les réseaux sociaux ne sont pas toujours très réactifs pour protéger les victimes.
Sauf quand on s’appelle Instagram et qu’une femme montre l’un de ses tétons, là d’un seul coup on réagit bien plus vite.
On va donc se pencher sur le sujet :
Comment les plateformes tentent de modérer les propos susceptibles d’enfreindre la loi ?
Les fake news peuvent-elles être condamnées ?
Mais surtout, on va élargir en se demandant si c’est souhaitable qu’un réseau social puisse agir de la même façon qu’un juge.
Accrochez-vous, on va devoir être un poil technique.
Si quelqu’un vous insulte via message privé sur Instagram et que vous voulez intenter une action en justice,
c’est le droit commun qui s’applique.
Le droit commun, ce sont les règles “de base”, celles qu’on applique le plus souvent,
par opposition au régime spécial
qui va recouper des situations plus spécifiques.
Si l’on vous insulte en public sur Twitter par exemple,
là on va justement appliquer un droit spécial,
puisqu’on incorpore cette infraction dans ce qu’on appelle les infractions commises par voie de presse.
Ça englobe évidemment les journaux, la radio, la télé mais surtout, Internet.
Dans la presse classique, on applique l’une des lois les plus célèbres, la loi de 1881 sur la liberté de la presse.
C’est une responsabilité en cascade, où on va poursuivre en premier lieu
telle personne et si c’est pas possible, on passe à l'échelon suivant.
En première intention, on va non pas se pencher sur l’auteur de l’article
mais sur le directeur de publication ;
Si on ne peut pas, soit parce-que pas de chance,
le directeur de publication est mort ou on n’arrive pas à l’identifier, ou qu’il ne se situe pas en France,
on poursuit alors l’auteur de l’article.
Si on n’arrive toujours pas identifier quelqu’un,
c’est l’imprimeur qui devient responsable.
Et si c’est toujours pas possible, ça retombera sur… le distributeur ou le vendeur de journaux.
Non, ne riez pas, ON VEUT DES COUPABLES !
Pour Internet, c’est un poil différent :
on s’appuie sur cette loi de 1881 mais on a été obligé de créer des textes spécifiques pour l’occasion,
comme la loi pour la confiance dans l'économie numérique du 21 juin 2004. On adore créer de nouveaux textes.
Deux hypothèses dans le cas d’Internet :
Si vous tenez un blog, un journal en ligne, un forum où les commentaires sont contrôlés et autorisés manuellement avant publication,
vous avez la charge de surveiller tout ce qui est publié sur votre site.
C’est ce qu’on appelle le devoir de vigilance et oui, c’est fastidieux ?
Vous êtes comme un “directeur de publication” et vous pouvez être tenus responsable des commentaires postés.
Donc, si quelqu’un se met à tenir des propos très sexistes sous votre article qui parle de votre amour des labradors,
c’est votre faute quand même.
En revanche, c’est très différent si vous êtes un hébergeur,
comme Twitter, Facebook, Instagram, YouTube, etc.
Avant la loi de 2004, il faut savoir que le droit était extrêmement favorable aux hébergeurs,
si bien que leur faute n’était quasiment jamais retenue, au détriment des victimes.
Désormais, le principe de base c'est que l’hébergeur n’a pas connaissance des contenus problématiques
car il n’exerce qu’une fonction “technique” mais il doit répondre à certains devoirs.
Si on rapporte un contenu illicite,
l’hébergeur doit réagir et il y a 2 hypothèses dans ce cas :
soit le modérateur considère que le contenu enfreint la loi et il le supprime.
Soit le modérateur a eu connaissance du message litigieux,
il a été prévenu et il l’a laissé, donc on peut engager sa responsabilité ;
En gros, Twitter, Instagram, Facebook n'ont aucune mission de surveillance
mais après la notification d’un contenu illicite,
ils ont un devoir de vigilance et de surveillance vis-à-vis de ce contenu spécifique.
L’hébergeur et le fournisseur d’accès ont tout intérêt à collaborer
car c’est à leur charge d’identifier les auteurs des contenus en question.
A défaut, c’est leur responsabilité qu’on engagera.
Bon mais ça c’est toujours la théorie…
Vous avez probablement, comme moi, signalé des contenus que vous trouviez particulièrement dangereux.
J’avais signalé un tweet qui appelait au viol de femmes
et la réponse de Twitter était qu’il ne voyait pas en quoi le compte avait enfreint les conditions d’utilisation de la plateforme.
Ben voyons.
Le problème est là, précisément.
Certains contenus passent au travers des mailles du filet car il y a énormément de messages, énormément de signalements à traiter.
Ce ne sont plus des modérateurs physiques qui prennent le relais mais des algorithmes.
Et un algorithme, pour qu’il soit efficace, il faut l’entrainer,
et ce n’est pas toujours évident pour une machine de faire la distinction entre une incitation au viol et une dénonciation du viol,
et encore pire si on parle d’un tweet un peu cynique par exemple.
L’impunité sur les réseaux sociaux n’est donc pas qu’une impression.
Vous pourriez me citer que Nikita Bellucci a obtenu la condamnation de certains de ses harceleurs,
à 18 mois de prison dont 3 mois fermes, c’est assez sérieux...
ou encore que Christiane Taubira a aussi obtenu la condamnation de l’auteur d’un tweet la comparant à un singe…
Mais ces condamnations ne reflètent pas l’état actuel de notre gestion de ces dérives.
Il est impossible d’avoir des chiffres qui font sens, mais entre le nombre de comportements susceptibles d’être condamnés et ceux qui le sont effectivement,
il y a un gouffre.
Ah oui, Jean-Michel Réverbe.
Ça me fait penser justement à Kick a Ginger Day.
Ça remonte maintenant à 2008.
Et à l’époque, c’était un ado de 14 ans
qui avait vu un épisode super sympa de South Park
qui s’appelle “Ginger Kids” et qui incite finalement
à mener une vendetta contre les gamins roux.
Le groupe facebook s’appelait “Kick a Ginger Day”
et ce groupe Facebook incitait à taper des roux
et il a réuni 5000 personnes, je crois.
Et, dans la vraie vie, il y a des gens qui se sont fait taper.
Des ados et des enfants, qui se sont fait taper par les autres juste parce qu’ils étaient roux.
La police s’en est mêlée, parce qu’il y a eu de vraies violences.
Le créateur du groupe, lui, il avait 14 ans, il s’est excusé, il a fermé le groupe et voilà.
Et ceux qui ont tapé des enfants, c’était des ados, ils ont fait quelques jours d’intérêts généraux.
Ils ont participé à des associations, ils se sont excusés et puis voilà.
Et en plus, comme tu dis, c’était des jeunes en fait.
Donc le juge, forcément, il ne va pas être très sévère avec les gamins.
Parce qu’on ne peut pas mettre un gamin en taule. Et le seul truc sur lequel je serais optimiste, c’est que c’était en 2008.
Et du coup, maintenant, on a beaucoup plus d’expériences par rapport aux cyber harcèlements, aux cyber violences et ce genre de choses.
Du coup, il y a plus de condamnations qu’à l’époque.
Parce que là, on était vraiment au début de Facebook en fait.
Mais on a mis du temps à prendre ça vraiment au sérieux et y a encore du chemin à faire.
Bon alors mon point de vue, je pense que vous le connaissez déjà un petit peu.
Dans de pareilles situations, la réponse pénale devrait être très rapide, puisqu’il n’y a pas besoin d’une enquête très approfondie pour savoir qu’inciter à taper un homosexuel,
c’est pénalement répréhensible et que plus tôt on supprimera ces propos, mieux ce sera.
Mais comme d’habitude, le manque de budget au sein de la Justice n’aide pas à avoir cette réponse pénale très rapide.
Comme n’importe quel autre service public, la Justice se meurt sous des coupes budgétaires dont les avocats, juges, greffiers et autres professionnels du droit s'alarment depuis…
30 ? 40 ? 50 ans ? Je ne sais pas.
Bon on parlait de la modération des propos discriminants et haineux,
mais qu’en est-il des fake news,
qui peuvent aussi faire l’objet de vérifications des modérateurs de la plateforme ?
Vous vous en souvenez probablement, en mai 2020, Donald Trump avait publié plusieurs tweets concernant le vote par correspondance
pour les élections présidentielles américaines dans le cadre de la crise du Covid 19.
Trump soutenait que le vote par correspondance serait forcément frauduleux,
en expliquant que n’importe qui vivant en Californie recevrait des bulletins,
alors que c’était factuellement faux puisque seuls ceux inscrits sur les listes électorales recevront bien ces courriers.
Twitter avait signalé ces tweets comme étant “potentiellement trompeurs”.
Puis, plus tard, Twitter a carrément désactivé la possibilité de repartager le tweet.
Un détail peut-être anodin aux yeux de beaucoup,
et pourtant les utilisateurs de la plateforme savent combien ces dispositions sont exceptionnelles et novatrices.
Bref, en modifiant les informations initiales, Donald Trump a répandu … une fake news.
Twitter a donc fait un travail de modération, en choisissant une méthode que je trouve pertinente.
Plutôt que de supprimer purement et simplement le tweet,
un message d’avertissement s’affichait au-dessus,
redigireant vers des informations plus étayées.
En l'occurrence, il s’agissait du Président des Etats-Unis, donc c’était un peu cocasse de le voir se faire reprendre par Twitter,
en même temps il faut dire que la portée des propos est démentielle.
Qu’en est-il de la personne comme vous et moi qui partagerait une fausse information ?
Et d’ailleurs, n’y a-t-il pas une différence entre une personne qui partage une fausse information en étant parfaitement consciente
qu’elle est fallacieuse et une personne qui la partage de bonne foi,
en croyant sincèrement ce qu’elle dit ?
La bonne foi est un principe très important en droit, et il me semble qu’ici, il est de mise d’y avoir à nouveau recours.
Sinon on pourrait condamner pénalement quelqu’un qui partage un contenu ne faisant pas consensus scientifiquement,
ça pourrait être un peu limite niveau liberté d’expression quand même.
Le truc, c’est que si je réponds aux rumeurs qui me concernent, même si c’est des fausses infos, automatiquement je vais les propager quoi.
Oui ça, c’est comme nettoyer une tache de merde avec un torchon trop humide.
À vouloir l’éliminer, tu l’étales sur la faïence.
Ça sent le vécu ça.
Mais après, y a des gens, si tu ne dis pas que c’est faux, ils vont y croire.
Oui exactement, du coup je suis coincé, il n’y a pas de solution.
Censurer ces vidéos ou ces posts
pourraient avoir malheureusement un effet contraire à celui espéré,
via l’effet Streisand.
L’effet Streisand, c’est lorsqu’on essaie d’empêcher la divulgation d’informations et que cela produit l’exact effet inverse.
Cet effet tire son origine de la chanteuse Barbra Streisand
qui avait poursuivi un paparazzi ayant publié des photos de sa maison.
Malheureusement pour elle, si ces photos étaient passées relativement inaperçues, la procédure en cours a eu une plus grande portée médiatique,
rendant les photos beaucoup plus visibles qu’elles ne l’étaient à l’origine.
Si par exemple, YouTube supprimait systématiquement les vidéos remettant en cause l’efficacité des vaccins,
est-ce-qu’on ne se mangerait pas un effet Streisand assez violent par la tête ?
Les personnes croyant à ces théories pourraient facilement user de cette rhétorique :
regardez, nos propos gênent, on cherche à nous faire taire, c’est bien que quelque part, il y a une part de vérité…
Finalement, est-ce-que l’effet ne serait pas contre-productif ?
C’est tout le problème des fake news.
Les personnes qui les diffusent et les personnes qui les débunkent sont très différentes et leurs bulles ne semblent pas tellement rentrer en collision.
Comment atteindre la cible des personnes diffusant des fake news, de façon malveillante ou au contraire, de bonne foi,
sans cultiver ce sentiment de censure ?
Pour lutter contre les fake news,
on a promulgué en France une loi, dite Loi contre la manipulation de l'information, en 2018.
Vous vous en souvenez peut-être, cette loi avait fait l’objet de nombreuses critiques au moment de sa discussion.
Il y a également eu un dispositif mis en place à Singapour en 2019 et en Allemagne en 2017
c’est le Netzwerkdurch...
Je sais pas si le cas de Valentine rentre vraiment dans le Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz.
Nan mais c’était juste pour que tu le dises.
Tu sais qu’on appelle ça aussi le “Facebook Act”, c’est moins chiant à dire, c’est moins carré aussi,
alors que Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz…
Littéralement, la loi d'application ou de contrôle des réseaux.
C’est clair, c’est efficace.
C’est Allemand.
Alors petit fun fact, des dispositions assez similaires existaient déjà dans une loi de 1849,
faut croire qu’à l’époque Internet était rempli de platistes et de théories comme les chemtrails…
On condamnait la publication de “nouvelles fausses” “de nature à troubler la paix publique”.
Ces dispositions ont par la suite étaient reprises dans la loi de 1881 sur la liberté de la presse.
Bref, la problématique n’était pas nouvelle et notre arsenal juridique pouvait déjà agir à l’encontre de ce type de difficultés.
La loi sur les fake news de 2018 prévoit le recours à l’action judiciaire en référé,
c'est-à-dire une procédure “accélérée” sur une période de 3 mois avant une élection nationale.
Déjà, ça coince, comme si les fake news ne posaient problème que dans le cadre d’une élection.
Le juge en charge aurait alors 48h pour statuer sur la question.
Le recours en référé n’est pas une procédure nouvelle,
c’est typiquement ce qu’on a utilisé comme procédure en pleine affaire Dieudonné !
Mais pour le coup, appliqué aux fake news, ça parait un peu plus ambitieux.
La loi prévoyait également un devoir de coopération entre les plateformes
et accordait de nouveaux pouvoirs au CSA
(le Conseil Supérieur de l’Audiovisuel, enfin la police de la télé quoi.)
Le principal reproche fait au texte c’est que précisément,
notre droit permettait déjà la condamnation de ces fausses nouvelles.
Ce n’est malheureusement pas rare que des lois se chevauchent et alourdissent notre législation,
C’est surtout la crainte d’un recul des libertés fondamentales qui agitait ceux qui s’opposaient à la loi.
La définition des fausses nouvelles paraissait trop floue, et quand c’est flou, on laisse ça à l’interprétation du juge,
ce qui peut totalement changer de l’un à l’autre et créer des ruptures d’égalité.
On craignait également que les plateformes censurent de façon excessive.
Et puis, bon, imaginons qu’on voit une fake news tourner,
faisant un lien entre la sclérose en plaques et les vaccins.
C’est une hypothèse que l’on voit pas mal tourner chez les antivaxs
mais qui ne représente pas DU TOUT le consensus scientifique.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'un juge en sait ?
Est-il compétent sur la question ?
J’ai fait du droit pendant 5 ans, j’ai pas trop le souvenir d’avoir eu beaucoup de cours de médecine sur la question.
Il faut être conscient des limites de notre compétence et de notre expertise
et s’en remettre à d’autres personnes qui connaissent le sujet.
Parce que clairement, non, dans une telle situation,
le juge ne peut pas être compétent,
et encore moins s’il doit prendre sa décision dans la précipitation.
La question que je me pose et qui m’a particulièrement donné envie de traiter le sujet
c’est la question : est-ce qu'on met en place les bonnes stratégies ?
Je ne vous parle pas du fait de supprimer des contenus incitant à la haine sur Internet,
ça évidemment que c’est nécessaire, je pense que je n’ai pas besoin de le préciser.
Mais est-ce-que c’est souhaitable que les modérateurs aient en charge de surveiller les sites sur lesquels ils officient ?
Force est de constater que la multitude de messages rend impossible une modération efficace,
à moins de mettre des milliers de modérateurs sur tous les fronts, ce qui me semble impossible.
Et c’est même, peu souhaitable, vu les témoignages que nous rapportent certains modérateurs sur les réseaux sociaux
qui avouent être traumatisés par l’exposition à des propos
voire des images parfois choquantes.
La jurisprudence a déjà pris acte de cette difficulté,
en ne condamnant que les modérateurs qui auraient consciemment laissé passer des propos intolérables
alors qu’ils en avaient été informés.
Ce que j’aime bien, c’est qu’il y a aussi l’idée d’une autorégulation, d’une responsabilité collective.
Si vous êtes témoins de quelque chose d’inacceptable, vous pouvez émettre ce signalement,
sur les réseaux sociaux ou sur la plateforme Pharos par exemple.
Malheureusement, pour que cette auto-régulation fonctionne, il faut aussi que les signalements soient traités rapidement
et efficacement ce qui demande… du budget.
LA THUNE, c’est un peu le nerf de la guerre.
L’autre question que je me pose c’est : est-ce-que le modérateur ne se substitue pas au juge ?
Je ne suis pas légaliste, mais je ne sais pas dans quelle mesure il est souhaitable que ce soit un modérateur, dont on ne connaît pas les sensibilités
ou la formation à ce type de problématique, qui soit en charge de surveiller du contenu.
Le modérateur me semble un échelon indispensable pour désengorger la justice et obtenir une réponse plus rapide.
Un modérateur peut supprimer des propos antisémites
plus vite que ne le fera n’importe quelle juridiction, et c’est ce qu’on souhaite.
Mais si l’on va plus loin, si quelqu’un tient des propos racistes à répétition et que Twitter par exemple
décide de le bannir définitivement.
Est-ce-que ce n’est pas une forme de sanction qui pourrait relever de la compétence exclusive d’une juridiction pénale ?
Ou on considère qu’en tant qu’entreprise privée, Twitter décide de qui a le droit de pénétrer sur son domaine ou non ?
Étant donné l’importance des réseaux sociaux dans notre vie,
l’exclusion de l’un d’eux peut avoir des conséquences importantes et c’est une façon de limiter la liberté d’expression.
D’ailleurs, en 2017, la Cour suprême des Etats-unis a décidé que l'accès aux réseaux sociaux
était un droit garanti par le premier amendement de la Constitution.
Une personne pourrait donc se voir supprimer son compte,
peut-être de façon abusive,
sans avoir pu se défendre,
avec pour seul juge le responsable du réseau social.
Est-ce que ce type de situation ne montrerait pas un basculement dans une justice privée ?
Bon, je suis juriste de formation, donc vous comprendrez aisément que si on commence à se substituer au juge,
ça me pose problème.
Mais, si on fait ça, ça veut peut-être dire que la justice est défaillante
et on sait bien qu’elle l’est souvent dans ces cas précis.
A terme, ce serait bien qu’on ambitionne peut-être de régler en profondeur ces difficultés propres à la Justice
pour ne plus avoir affaire à la justice privée, encore plus s’il s’agit de la justice d’une.. entreprise.
En ce sens, Reporter Sans Frontières avait publié des contrepropositions
en réaction à la loi contre les fakes news de 2018, dont une que je trouve particulièrement intéressante.
Reporter Sans Frontières voudrait un texte de loi consacré de façon très spécifique
à l’impact qu’ont les entreprises privées sur la diffusion,
l’accès à l’information et sur l’intégrité du débat public.
Selon RSF, il faudrait exiger beaucoup plus de transparence de la part de ces plateformes,
que ce soit sur la promotion des contenus,
une transparence et une neutralité des algorithmes,
une promotion de l’intégrité de l’information etc.
N’oublions pas que derrière les réseaux sociaux que nous utilisons chaque jour se trouvent les GAFAM,
une concentration d’entreprises très puissantes dans une position de monopole.
Il serait intéressant de se pencher sur comment limiter leur influence et leurs pouvoirs, y compris dans la diffusion des informations qu’on trouve dessus
mais aussi dans la modération de ces informations.
Est-ce-que c’est souhaitable de beaucoup légiférer sur les fake news,
de faire en sorte de les supprimer au maximum ?
Ou au contraire, cela va-t-il provoquer un énorme sentiment de censure et donc, un genre d’effet Streisand qui serait encore pire ?
Il faut scinder le problème en deux :
lutter contre les oppressions et les discriminations sur les réseaux sociaux
peut être pris en charge pour partie par les réseaux sociaux
car leur réponse sera toujours plus rapide que celle de n’importe quelle juridiction.
Les juridictions peuvent ensuite prendre le relai en fonction de la gravité et de la récurrence des propos tenus.
Mais pour ce qui est des fake news, ça semble différent.
Ce qui me pose problème, c’est qu’on puisse censurer tout ce qui ne fait pas consensus scientifique par exemple.
L’idée de totalement fermer le débat public me semble entrer en conflit avec la liberté d’expression,
qui est un droit fondamental.
Mais là où certains arguments ou données scientifiques par exemple sont soumises au débat public,
c’est différent pour les discriminations.
On peut être pour ou contre le nucléaire, mais on ne peut pas être pour ou contre les homosexuels.
Certains propos ne sont pas des opinions, ils sont des délits.
Pour les fake news, il me semble donc plus pertinent d’avoir recours à de multiples acteurs.
Cela va des instances classiques (nos assemblées parlementaires, nos tribunaux) aux réseaux sociaux, aux journalistes,
aux citoyens dans leur globalité.
C’est un travail commun, complémentaire,
puisqu’une société qui s’en remettrait à une seule institution considérée comme le tribunal de la vérité,
serait le signe d’une société malade et très peu démocratique.
Ces acteurs multiples pourraient donc s’autoréguler,
comme lorsqu’on vous dit que les pouvoirs exécutifs, législatifs et judiciaires s’équilibrent naturellement
et se limitent les uns les autres.
Et ben, c’est pas gagné.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo, n’hésitez pas à la commenter, à la liker.
On se retrouvera sur Discord pour en discuter, n’hésitez pas à rejoindre le Discord du Vortex.
et si vous regardez cette vidéo au moment de sa sortie, je suis actuellement en live sur Twitch,
donc n’hésitez pas à venir en discuter tous ensemble.
Et s’il vous plaît, ne laissez pas de commentaires haineux, sinon vous n’aurez rien retenu de ce que je viens de dire, ce serait embêtant.
Eh bah bravo florence, t’as miné le moral de Valentine j’espère que tu es fière de toi.
Nan mais là, c’est toi qui n’aide pas Monté.
Remarque, si tu veux bien faire un truc pour moi, je pense que ça nous fera du bien à tous les deux.
- C'est-à-dire que...
- Non attend, ce n'est pas ce que tu crois.
Si jamais tu veux bien mettre Florent dehors, au moins, je ne verrais pas sa gueule chaque jour en me levant le matin,
et ça me ferait probablement un peu de bien.
Franchement Valentine, après tout ce qu’on a vécu,
t’es vraiment une pote.
C’est comme si c’était fait.
Tu t'es comporté comme un gros dégueulasse, donc désolé de t'annoncer que...
(*inaudible*)
Regarde, ta guitare, ta guitare, regarde.
Salut !
Mange-mort !